fires for the government expecting
another night of widespread looting
people of New York are begging for word
during the collapse of New York City
many hostile factions rose using the
devastation and lawlessness to quickly
gain power in territory in the area one
of those factions is the ruckus the
Rikers are probably one of the most
straightforward factions in the division
with these guys what you see is what you
get there is no hidden agendas within
this group they simply want to create
chaos in the wake of the outbreak the
Rikers originated on Rikers Island which
totally explains their name now that I
think about it Rikers Island as New York
City's main jail complex the island is
home to one of the world's largest
correctional facilities and mental
institutions it has an average
population of 10,000 inmates at any time
Rikers has a reputation for abuse and
neglect and is ranked as one of the
worst correctional facilities in the
United States following the outbreak of
the green poison prison guards stopped
turning up to work and a number of the
ones that did was sick with the virus
medical support and supplies were cut
off from the island as the general
consensus from officials and the public
was that resources would better spent on
the public on the mainland essentially
the prisons were being left to fend for
themselves until the situation on the
mainland had been dealt to the inmate
population was compiled of various gang
members but given the situation they
decided to unite under a single leader
and as one unit they were able to
organize an escape from the island but
how did they escape Rikers Island the
reduced guard presence made it
relatively easy for the guards to be
overpowered taking the guards as
hostages allowed them to make their way
through security and once they had a
clear run up the island any one of the
badge was executed in a bloody brutal
fashion this new collaboration was a
group of thieves and murderers and their
ruthless now organized the main
objective was simple enact revenge on
authorities kill everyone with the
uniform especially the JTF the next
challenge was how they would get off the
island and onto the mainland the leader
of this group of inmates Lara Barrett
had discovered an administrator of the
prison had a bit of a thing for Lara and
through this relationship the
administrator had organized a barge so
they could sail away into the sunset
together but this relationship didn't
last long as soon as the plan was set in
motion Lara cut the administrator's
throat and this is the president of how
the Rikers would gain their dominance
over New York City what they lack in
technology and training they more than
make up with violence and aggression
their goal to take advantage of the
current situation in New York and claim
ownership for themselves while
slaughtering as many uniformed
authorities as possible
Lara Barrett was imprisoned at Rikers
Island for double murder she is
treacherous ruthless and unforgiving she
shows no remorse for her actions and
despises Authority of any kind
that's a fact and you felt it was
appropriate to pull the gun you had hit
on your person in self-defense my quiet
the feared for her life and shot two
officers both family men incidentally in
the back of the head execution-style at
point-blank range that is a curious kind
of self-defense you're smiling Barrett
something you want to share just having
me a nice memory
you know nothing to do was shooting two
innocent men in the back of the head
just puppies and baby doll and flowers
and all that [ __ ] this is speculation
detective let's stick to the facts you
know I ain't nothing but sugar and spice
and everything nice it was Lara who
convinced the inmates to join up through
stating they're together the numbers
were dominate but separately they would
be back under the thumb of the
government she has a very intimidating
presence torturing both captured JTF
officers and rebellious Rikers to bring
a gang into compliance who followers do
so under fear if you're not with her
you're against her and we'll meet the
same fate as the authority figures that
she hates so much once establishing
themselves on the mainland the Rikers
had no problems boosting their numbers
even further as the local gangs heard
about their movement and were eager to
join of course with the sim flux of new
recruits gained some power struggles to
this however is kept at bay by Lara
Barrett known as much for a ruthlessness
as a rebuilding plan organize and lead
Barrett's powerful leadership of the
members show that the Rikers gang is not
to be missed it
when I was in Rikers one of the girls
got a hold of this pain stuck it right
on the back of my head so I took that
pen and gave a ride back to her and
wouldn't you know it went straight to
her I sliced open and [ __ ] all over the
inside of her mouth but that wasn't
enough so I got the biggest room and
after I finished stabbing her
well that was that point I don't do
second chances
[Applause]
Barrett encouraged brutality towards the
JTF
telling her followers of the
government's plan to leave them to
starve and die on Rikers Island and they
must be punished in the most horrific
new reports have come in saying that JT
of bodies have been found and were
killed in some of the worst ways
possible
the Rikers were getting creative with
their methods they were making a
statement it was becoming a game a sport
the majority of the Wreckers gears from
the clothing of uniformed officers that
have killed as well as the bulletproof
armor and weapons survival wasn't so
easy on the mainland a lot of the food
and water had already been pillaged by
rioters and civilians in need
fortunately for the Rikers the growing
rumors of Barrett's brutality and
ruthlessness were able to be used to
secure supplies for the members my
people you're gonna find that food and
you're gonna give it to the people of my
choosing
created and anything you can yeah
yeah eventually enough was enough
the JT have found with Lara Barrett and
the Ryker suits set up camp and sent in
the division agents to take them down
the Rikers were using the Lexington
Events Center as their HQ the JT of
officers that found the hideout were
taken hostage so the first step was to
rescue the JTF and then shut down the
Rikers by taking out Lara Barrett
immediately upon entering the event
center it was obvious that this had been
uses an area to humiliate and torture
the JTF you know that song the one about
the bridge dam is the name of that [ __ ]
you know that guy sings it I can't play
piano don't be shy there boys every
party needs some music wait I used to be
in a band I think I know the one
Mylene
[Music]
after rescuing the hostages
JT of officers joined up with the second
wave agents to assist in the final fight
against the well defended Lara Barrett
even in the last moments Barrett
continued to preach to her followers and
show maximum disrespect towards the
government and authorities without Lara
Barrett the Rikers threat was
considerably reduced and house fighting
started and they were pushed into hiding
even though she was not referenced much
after her death it's clear how much of
an effect who death had on maracas the
planning and ruthless leadership of
Barrett would never be replaced but the
Rikers were not down and out yet
audio logs found in the underground show
that the Rikers are now aware of the
divisions identity and expressed their
hate towards them the attack on the
Lexington Events Center had been forced
to retreat from the fancy apartments
they took over down to the filthy
conditions of the underground they don't
seem to be aware of the treason of the
first wave agents as the new leader of
the Rikers talks about a mysterious
speaker that smells like division but
still accepts who are offering weapons
and return for attacking the quarantine
Center the Rikers are continually
looking for payback
against the division and this has been
shown through encounters like clear
skies and a massive attack that was
launched on the news agency in the
stolid signal battle as I said earlier
there isn't any hidden surprises with
this group all of the recordings and
Intel available just goes into further
detail outlining how aggressive and
brutal they are towards the government
and authorities figures there a horde of
released criminals from Rikers Island
there were nothing more than to return
to the streets that wreaked havoc on in
the past anyway thank you for watching
the next video will be on the last man
battalion and this would wrap up the
main factions at a plan on covering if
you have a specific division story you'd
like me to discuss let me know in the
comments Cheers
one cuts gonna make you bleed but one
cut don't kill you what cut just makes
the score you can turn it into a whimper
that's your choice to be a victim in a
prison cell or even free-rolling in your
own streets again complain about the
cold the rats
complain about who's in charge some
people want to stay the victor they want
to cry I'll give you what you want you
want to be the victor make you want me
imma take what's mine
they say this disease is a tragedy the
end of the world is our teacher
big job teaching us to rise up they take
it from us long enough now you take from
the houses that cost their families
their lives this is our town and now is
our time
[Applause]
[Music]